I'm Jimmy phela I'm Madison allworth I'm
Bill hemmer and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday
April 12th 2023
I'm Dave Anthony it's a league the U.S
has been trying to pluck of classified
documents detailing sensitive American
intelligence there's a negative
potential impact on our sources who are
now questioning whether the super secret
information that they're giving us at
grave risk to themselves it's worth it
because they don't want to get a bullet
in the back of the head Elisa Brady a
parental rights movement sows fertile
ground for progress on school choice so
this is a natural outgrowth of policies
that are supporting family Empowering
Families and choices for kids and I'm
Tommy lahren I've got the final word on
the Fox News Rundown
who's leaking American Secrets that's a
big question in Washington where
Senators want a classified briefing
about classified documents found online
detailing sensitive U.S intelligence
Republican Congresswoman Nancy mace
tells Fox the administration literally
has no answers and so if they can't keep
our top secrets safe then how can they
keep us safe I mean this is just another
example of us projecting weakness the
documents were first posted weeks ago on
a gaming site Discord then spread other
places most appear to have come from a
briefing book prepared daily for The
Joint Chiefs and U.S commanders overseas
but Fox's Jennifer Griffin at the
Pentagon also reports some of the leaks
did not come from those books they
appear to be produced by other U.S
intelligence agencies like the CIA and
NSA some of the most damaging leaks have
to do with South Korea the United Arab
Emirates Israel and Egypt for instance
one of the more Dam Imaging documents
concerns Egypt which has received 50
billion dollars in U.S military aid
since 1978 reporting suggests president
CeCe of Egypt plan to secretly ship
forty thousand Rockets to Russia for use
in Ukraine at the same time that he was
holding friendly phone calls with
president zielinski that is just one of
the many bits of leaked U.S Intel
related to the war in Ukraine so who is
doing this and why there are many more
unanswered questions right now of course
than there are answers Daniel Hoffman is
a retired CIA senior clandestine
Services officer now a Fox News
contributor a few things that I would be
concerned about first of all we don't
know if this is the extent of the secret
documents that have been stolen some
have been disseminated but there could
yet be more secondly there is no
question that the motive behind stealing
these documents was to hurt the United
States of America
for wondering about it this is clear
weaponization of classified information
the possibilities are are pretty I would
say expansive in terms of who was
responsible it could have been a
malicious Insider like Snowden or
Chelsea Manning uh it could have been a
non-state uh a state actor like Russia
or China acting alone and stealing this
information and then disseminating it or
it could have been a combination of the
two where the Russians or Chinese
recruited a source and then used that
source to steal the documents I don't
think it was a a non-state act or a
hacking group there's no money to be
made in this operation just a lot of
risk because you've got a bullseye on
you from the US government all right
well you say not hacking but how else
would you know and rushing like a
hacking criminal group okay less likely
okay uh that it's a not that it's just
some criminal hacking group I think much
more likely that it's a it's a state
actor responsible for this but I'm sure
the Russians are enjoying the fact that
this intelligence leak is is being
weaponized against the United States and
as you pointed out some of the
information that was leaked is certainly
designed to drive a wedge between the
United States and our key allies that
would be South Korea Ukraine obviously
turkey uh and Egypt and Israel and that
would be the key ones there's a report
in the New York Times that Tuesday in
South Korea opposition lawmakers were
angry because they say that these
documents show that the U.S has been
spying on our Ally and we've learned
supposedly about a lot of South Korean
weapons being made and sent over to
Ukraine one other thing that came out of
this story is that defense secretary
Austin and the defense minister of South
Korea supposedly agreed that quite a few
of the documents in this leak were
fabricated
uh-huh so right so the question is how
much of this material is accurate well
that's a question so right now let's
start with that point which is a really
good one who might have had access to
this information what's been fabricated
the Russian modus operandi is to take
something that's true let's say 95 true
and then sprinkle their secret sauce of
disinformation to design to influence uh
thinking about a particular issue and so
it's certainly possible that that's what
we're seeing in this case the problem
that we're having though with our allies
is this is the kind of stuff you don't
want to be exposed publicly there even
if it's not true it's going to have kind
of a life of its own a force multiplier
where people will be reading this and
there's blowback politically on our
allies South Koreans have a law which
prohibits them from providing military
equipment which would be used in War and
what was alleged in those documents is
that South Korea was shipping the United
States our attorney Hillary and we were
sending it on to Ukraine so even if
that's not true and we know that there
have been plenty of things out on the
internet that aren't true but that still
have an impact that's of concern to us
and uh the the only way to get at it is
to be transparent about our
investigation and to be really forceful
about putting the truth out there with
an eye towards maybe drowning out the
propaganda lies but that's extremely
challenging the last point I'll make for
you is
the intelligence Community just like
Department of Defense and our national
security writ large it's a zero-sum game
if I'm spending 20 hours a day on a task
force designed to do the forensics and
damage assessment from this secret
document leak I'm not doing other stuff
and if if diplomatically we're talking
about these secret documents and the
impact they're going to have on our
bilateral relationships with Egypt and
Israel and others I'm not doing other
things that are important and that's of
grave concern to me as well one of the
other things that comes out of all this
is how we've been successful supposedly
at infiltrating Russia's intelligence
look we're really good at what we do and
that's what I did for a living recruit
spies and steal secrets and we had a
saying at the CIA an old Mentor of mine
used to say which was the secret of our
success is the secret of our success and
when something like this pops out into
the open that's just not very good for
us because we don't do this for any
public Acclaim uh we don't want any
public acknowledgment of what we do it
should be in the shadows and in the
background and and there's a negative
potential impact on our sources who are
now questioning whether the super secret
information that they're giving us at
grave risk to themselves is worth it
because they don't want to get a bullet
in the back of the head because Vladimir
Putin is now reading intelligence that
you know he he has to wonder where is it
coming from you know and so the other
question I would just again lots of
questions to ask but one is were these
documents leaked and were they altered
after they were on the Internet or were
they stolen and then altered and then
put out on the internet I mean these are
additional questions that we must be
asking so look there's a lot of work to
be done on this and uh at the end of the
day all we know for sure it's a major
counterintelligence flap for this
Administration and President Biden
should remember very well previous ones
he had to deal with because it was
during the Obama Administration that
they had to face Chelsea Manning and
Snowden Dan is referencing two other
massive security breaches Chelsea
Manning was an Army intelligence analyst
who Elite classified military documents
related to the Iraq and Afghanistan Wars
and more Wikileaks posted it all online
Manning was convicted of Espionage theft
and aiding the enemy in 2013 but four
years later President Obama commuted her
35-year prison sentence setting her free
2013 was also the same year Edward
Snowden leaked classified intelligence
while working for the National Security
Agency the NSA detailing widespread U.S
surveillance programs he fled the
country to avoid being charged Russia
gave him Asylum and last year made
Snowden a Russian citizen so how do
those massive breaches size up to this
new one I don't think we know yet and I
would be very wary of speculating on
just how bad these leaks are because
they're probably not done yet maybe this
is the first of of a number of tranches
we just don't know so is this stuff
coming from the CIA from the defense
department
all of the above anywhere else where is
it all coming from right and that it may
be coming from all of those places and
that's another thing that I expect our
task force will be looking at uh exactly
where the information came from and also
just important to bifurcate what looks
like it's accurate what is accurate and
what isn't so look like I said it's
early days on this very early days we
have to be careful about speculating too
much about how this compares to other
breaches but you know once we have more
information about exactly what was
stolen then I think we'll feel like we
can start to make some of those
conclusions but look as you could you
rightly know this is a major issue for
us and it's going to take a lot of the
oxygen out of our
um our relationships with important
allies at a crucial time and it's going
to take a lot of of man and woman powers
out of our intelligence Community to try
to do the forensics and the Damage
assessment I mean you can shut down like
the Discord server and you can stop that
but how how do you what what
since you don't exactly know yet the
source of all this how do you stop this
leak
can you I don't think you can if you
think about the numbers of people who
would have had access to this
intelligence and I'm sure someone has
already looked at that
it's like looking for a needle in a
stack of needles really hard to do it
and and that's also extremely time
consuming to do this kind of work it's
typically we catch spies because another
spy told us who the Spy is that's how we
got Rick games that's how we got Hanson
and others in this case
you know we learned about this because
we found it on the internet not because
some foreign spy told us that we have a
spy in our own midst and that just makes
it extraordinarily difficult but I can
tell you from my experience that the
sources with whom I had the honor of
working all over the world took
extraordinary risks on behalf of U.S
national security to protect U.S
citizens and there was nothing that was
more important to us as CIA officers
than protecting those people our sources
and that's why when something like this
happens it really can have a very
significantly negative impact on the
calculus that an individual might make
before they agree to be one of our
sources that's the the concern that I
would have so the people who do the jobs
now that you used to do
are what extremely nervous worried upset
angry what are they uh well the leaving
the emotional side out of it because
they you know you don't really my
experiences I just don't want to waste
my time on that I'm going to work the
problem and I'm going to meet my source
and I'm going to make sure that I button
down the trade craft so that I'm running
my sources securely as as I possibly can
it's up to the individual CIA case
officer out there in the field on the
front lines many Behind Enemy Lines In
Harm's Way to do everything they can to
protect the sources that we have and
reassure them that we're doing that and
then when they go out to recruit news
sources to reassure those new sources
that that we can protect them but but
our job got a lot more difficult because
of a leak back home and and yes that's
I'm sure there were a few expletives in
far-flung places all over the world
before they got back to work Daniel
Hoffman retired CIA senior clandestine
Services officer and a Fox News
contributor thanks very much for joining
us all right
[Music]
this is Tommy lahren with your Fox News
commentary coming up
Universal school choice programs are
springing up around the country State of
Florida is number one when it comes to
education freedom and education Choice
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis recently
signing a bill that expands the state's
existing program dropping restrictions
including income limits to make all
students eligible the largest expansion
of Education choice not only in the
history of this state but in the history
of these United States that is a big
deal the Florida teachers union says the
program will take billions of dollars
away from already underfunded classrooms
accusing the governor of putting
political ambition ahead of Florida's
families supporters say it's a
revolution to fund students not systems
with several States passing Universal
choice so far this year it certainly has
a lot of momentum now and it's thrilling
to see former U.S education secretary in
long time school choice Advocate Betsy
DeVos after toiling in the fields for 35
years
on behalf of policies like this that
we're seeing States now adopt really
across the country it's very exciting to
see and it's really in my view the
beginning of an exciting phase for K-12
education experiences
what's driving these latest school
choice programs I mean was locked down
the Tipping Point
I think when parents had a front row
seat to see exactly what was going on
and what was happening or what wasn't
happening in their children's schools
during the distance learning or whatever
iteration of observation of covid a
family had it really was revealing to so
many families who before thought their
kids were doing just fine in a school
they probably chose to live in that
particular district for and it really
did spur the momentum and the numbers
around families who were ultimately
unsatisfied with what they saw
let's break down one of the newest
expansions of school choice
um signed into law by Florida's governor
because I know funding is always a
concern with programs like this
Florida's new law envisions the money
following the student but doesn't say
exactly what it could cost or where all
of the money will come from the basic
model though you know seems to be a
family opting for Choice gets their
District's share of per student funding
for that student do I have that right
and is that sustainable
yes yes generally speaking when we're
talking about Universal education
savings accounts most of the states that
have joined that bandwagon in the last
several months or year are doing so with
the funding levels that are
approximately 90 percent of what the
states spends on that child already so
instead of the state paying for that
child to go to their assigned District
school that money goes with that child
and that family to choose the place
that's going to work best for him or her
so this is a natural outgrowth of
policies that are supporting family
Empowering Families and uh choices for
kids
one of the criticisms of that though is
that as it focuses you know more on
individual students and empowers
families it also takes money away from
the public school because of that shift
you know what about that criticism I
mean is that a legitimate concern
well if the investment is in the child
then the child is no longer in that
school then the school doesn't have
responsibility for that child's
education and this has really been an
important continued learning and there
have been many studies done on the
Florida situation and it's very telling
to note that in the districts where the
greatest percentage of students are
going to schools other than their
assigned District school whatever that
choice might be the achievement levels
for the students within that District
have all actually continued to improve
and I I believe it's because the schools
are making adjustments and making
changes that they wouldn't before when
they didn't have anything or anyone else
to compare themselves to so it's a
win-win for every student no matter
where they are I was going to ask you
where magnet and Charter Schools fit
into the Choice picture because they're
actually run by public schools right so
if you have this education account or a
voucher it wouldn't be used toward
tuition
correct well let's distinguish between a
magnet school a magnet school is a
school within a district that is uh
often uh focused on one specific area of
study or interest so it might be uh
theater in the arts for example or it
might be stem focused but it is a part
of the district system and run by the
district and the thing with magnet
schools is that the schools are
permitted to screen for students that
are appropriate for that school so if
they have an academic hurdle to go over
they can test students and they can take
in children who they deemed prepared for
whatever they have to offer a charter
school by contrast is also a public
school but it's run independent from the
school district
so when we talk about school choice and
the funding that families have access to
it's is it is it mainly for tuition at
things like private schools or can it
also be used for instructional materials
if you're if you're not using it for a
private school for instance you know
what or does it vary by state
it it really can be used to customize
any child's education so let's say for
um a child in Florida they are um in a a
you know small town uh high school that
has
um a nice you know round of offerings
for you know types of classes but that
it doesn't have perhaps uh two or three
of the subject areas maybe there's a
language the student wants or needs or a
particular uh science class or something
that the school can't offer this student
can take the education savings account
and apply you know a bulk of it toward
the school that he or she already
attends and then take some of it to
perhaps buy an online course taught by a
really great Professor on the other side
of the world I was surprised to read
actually how many states
allow all online learning options as
part of the curriculum and I don't mean
homeschooling necessarily just the kind
of creative things that you're talking
about
yeah exactly and you know there there
are many great online platforms and
providers and you know many families
actually migrated to those during uh all
of the lockdowns and shutdowns because
they you know they saw in many cases
very high quality options that they you
know and they ended up seeing how well
they worked for some kids now that's not
for every child just like sitting you
know lined up in rows of desks in a
classroom isn't the best environment for
every child to learn so it really it
really does Center our focus of
Education what education actually should
be learning and preparing to become you
know contributing members of society it
focuses it around where it should be the
student and helping him or her really
develop their innate talents and gifts
to the fullest extent I did want to ask
you about one of the other criticisms
that tends to come up about school
choice programs and that's the argument
that wealthier parents already paying
for a private school for instance don't
necessarily need this help
uh and I think that's largely the case
but I think that the states that are
passing Universal programs recognize and
acknowledge that this option and this
opportunity should be there for every
child in that state and I suspect that
the highest percentage of families who
will opt into and use these education
savings account programs will be lower
income families and and many middle to
you know upper middle income families
now again I think it's going to Foster
creativity around uh education
experiences that we haven't even really
begun to dream about because we've been
so used to education for K-12 students
being provided largely the same way for
175 years
is there a way
to offer school choice but still lift up
and improve public schools at the same
time I mean it sounds like you're you
know pretty much saying that that's
actually a byproduct of school choice is
lifting up the public schools yes it is
absolutely and again I refer to Florida
that has done you know there's been a
number of longitudinal studies done
about the impact that education Freedom
programs have had here and and let me
just interject here I like to use the
term education Freedom versus school
choice because I think it helps us think
more broadly Beyond specific buildings
to a much more
um holistic approach to what education
can look like for every child it gets
Beyond you know School building walls
but what we've seen in Florida is where
those students are in districts that
have a higher percentage of kids
choosing a school other than their
assigned District school all of the kids
achievement levels have continued to go
up and I think that's only going to
accelerate from here as uh more families
take this opportunity to really examine
what is going to work best for each of
their children
nearly 40 Years of advocacy I'm sure
you've heard it all the praise and the
complaints
how is this issue evolved you know what
do families who utilize education
Freedom programs tell you about the
decisions they've made and how it's
impacted their kids
it has been so inspiring anytime I feel
in any way discouraged all I need to do
is pick up the phone or see you know
face to face any one of a number of
individuals that I've gotten to know
over the years whose lives literally
have changed because their families had
the opportunity to access one of these
very early small programs and States
across the country are now recognizing
how important it is for families to have
that empowerment and for kids to be able
to find their right fit more than 30
states have some version of school
choice now or you optimistic about the
rest
I am ultimately I think look I think in
this is very quickly going to be also
become an economic competitiveness issue
because when uh businesses today are
trying to attract new younger workers to
whatever they have to offer in terms of
a job the first thing that a young
family does is check the quality of the
academic offerings in any any city or
state or uh you know or town and and
those states that continue to be tied to
the you know the government-run school
Union benefactors are going to continue
to fall further and further behind as a
result
former education secretary Betsy DeVos
thank you so much for your time
thanks so much Lisa great talking with
you
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi the
Bronze Age featured a number of
advancements irrigation the invention of
the wheel and now tripping on
hallucinogens three thousand year old
locks of hair that likely belong to
shamans were discovered in a burial
chamber in the Mediterranean island of
Menorca which belongs to Spain they
tested positive for a number of
mind-altering compounds suggesting the
people who live there Incorporated
hallucinogenic experiences into their
rituals the findings published in the
scientific reports of the journal Nature
suggest the first direct evidence of
ancient European hallucinogen use
researchers say the drugs were consumed
over the period of a year and well
before death although there's no way to
know why those ancient people were
consuming such powerful drugs the lead
researcher notes the tubes in which the
hair were found were decorated with
concentric circles which researchers say
may represent the inner Vision shamans
experienced after ingesting
hallucinogenic plants but they also say
they're still they need to learn for the
Fox News rundown I'm Gianna jalosi
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
I'm Dana Perino join me for season three
of my limited time podcast everything
will be okay based on my best-selling
book of the same name make sure you
subscribe to this series wherever you
download podcasts and leave a rating and
review subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary Tommy Lauren what's
on your mind welcome to the rainbow
Arrow where women of all shape sizes and
races are being replaced by white men
and all the while the feminists keep
quiet or cheer it on there's no bigger
cheerleader than the bite Administration
which recently released new guidelines
to make it easier for men to dress up as
women and run roughshod over what used
to be women's only categories new Title
IX regulations would essentially make it
more difficult for schools and colleges
to keep bio males out of women's sports
under these new rules no school or
college that receives Federal funding
would be allowed to impose a
one-size-fits-all policy that
categorically bans transgender students
from playing on sports teams consistent
with their gender identity if so that
institution would be in violation of
Title IX Title IX was put in place 50
years ago to further women's rights and
opportunities but it's been put through
the shredder and the party that
supposedly fights for women is leading
the charge conservatives are the new
feminist bet you didn't see that one
coming I'm Tommy lahren and you can
watch my show Tommy Laren Israelis at
outkick.com
foreign
[Music]
to the Fox News rundown now and now stay
up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad
free on FOX News podcasts Plus on Apple
podcast and Prime members can listen to
the show ad free on Amazon music and for
up to the minute news go to foxnews.com
it's will Kane co-host of Fox and
Friends Weekend join me as I share my
thoughts on a wide range of topics from
Sports and pop culture to politics and
business so will Kane podcast subscribe
and listen now at foxnewspodcasts.com or
wherever you get your podcasts
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes